[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEX FAABORG: Well,
before we do a deep dive
on the fundamental
principles of AR design,
I want to give you a quick
recap of what's new in ARCore
this year, specifically,
five things--
Scene Viewer, improvements
to Cloud Anchors,
improvements to Augmented
Images, Augmented Faces,
and a new set of lighting APIs
that we call Environmental HDR.
Let's take a look at
each of these in detail.
Scene Viewer is a 3D
AR immersive viewer
that lets you that runs
natively on Android
and allows users to seamlessly
put any 3D content that they
might encounter on a
website into their world.
Here we see an
example of how NASA
is able to quickly
let users place a Mars
Rover in their living room
just by hosting the glTF
file on their website.
And developers and designers
don't have to worry about all
of the subtle details of
AR object manipulation,
because you get all of this
functionality for free.
Next up, Cloud Anchors--
Cloud Anchors enable developers
to create multiplayer
and social AR experiences.
Technology, at times,
can be a bit isolating.
But that changes when you're
designing applications in AR
thanks to Cloud Anchors.
Users aren't just engaged
with the world around them,
but they can be more engaged to
the people around them as well.
This year, we're also adding
a number of improvements
to augmented images in ARCore.
And these can be used in a
wide range of different use
cases, things like retail
and educational experiences.
Here we see a user that's
learning about features
in an expresso machine.
And this is a
small-scale use of it.
But it can also be
very large-scale,
and it can scale all the
way up to large venues.
At I/O this year, we've
actually placed 50 signposts
throughout the campus at
various different locations.
These help users
with wayfinding.
So if you're not at I/O, and
you're watching on video,
here's how this works.
You can look at one
of these markers,
these augmented images.
And then we get an AR
layer that's superimposed
on top of the conference.
You can just find all the
different venues or sandboxes
that you're trying to
navigate or wayfind to.
Of course, the
front camera can be
just as important, if
not more important,
than the back camera on devices.
So this year, ARCore
is also adding
support for augmented faces.
ARCore provides a
468-point 3D mesh
the tracks head movements and
changing facial expressions.
And we use machine
learning to do all of this
without requiring a depth
sensor or any special hardware
on the device.
And this works with existing
phones out in the market.
ARCore teams also
leverage machine
learning to make really
dramatic improvements
in our light
estimation API, which
we call Environmental HDR.
Here's a quick example.
I'll start by
placing a rocket out
in the scene starting
with no light source.
But then I'll just add a quick
directional light source.
And this is how AR
has previously worked.
It's not particularly well-lit.
But now we can actually add
ambient spherical harmonics,
a cube map--
I'll turn the cube map on--
and then finally,
Environmental HDR.
And working together,
these lighting APIs
actually make the shadows and
lighting considerably more
realistic.
Here's the final stage
here as we turn in--
turn on Environmental HDR.
It takes it a bit of a moment
to understand the scene.
You can see that
start to lock in.
And then as you
move around, you get
really realistic lighting
reflections and shadows
on the objects.
Here's another example
with Environmental HDR.
This time, it's just
being turned on and off.
The mannequin on the left is
in AR, and the one on the right
is real--
well, not actually
real, it's a mannequin.
But you get the idea.
And you can see
really dramatic change
as Environmental HDR
is being turned on.
And then finally,
here's one more example.
In this case, the light
source is actually moving.
And you can the system
actually adapt in real time
and start to change the virtual
light source in response
to the change in the
real light source.
The team's really made
significant jumps this year
in the fidelity, realism, and
immersion that AR apps can
provide to users.
But as great as these
new technologies are,
it's equally important
that your AR app is also
really well-designed.
Khushboo, Germain, and Eugene or
from the ARCore UX design team.
And they'll get you up to
speed on the fundamentals of AR
interface design.
KHUSHBOO HASIJA: Thank you.
Thank you, Alex.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Khushboo, UX
researcher on ARCore.
I'm here to share some
insights about AR design.
And we can group AR
design fundamentals
in four rough categories--
environment, user, AR
content, and interface.
Sorry.
So first, let's talk
about environment.
In AR, we define environment as
physical environment as well as
augmented environment.
Physical environment is a real
world inhabited by our users
it could be indoors, as
you see, or outdoors.
So the first step to
designing an AR experience
is to define where user
will be using your app,
and then accordingly select
the environment up front.
And we recommend that once you
are defining the environment up
front, help users
identify what could
be the ideal conditions
for using your app
in their environment or space--
an augmented environment,
a virtual environment
rendered by ARCore by
integrated virtual content
with the real world.
In order to create an
augmented environment,
ARCore is continuously
improving its understanding
of the real world
and providing you
with surfaces where you
can land your assets
or build your
experience further.
By you creating
an AR experience,
you can leverage
ARCore's capability
to build surfaces over
time to your advantage.
For example, as you
see on the screen here,
a frog is jumping
from one surface
to another and encouraging
users to explore the space.
And here, while the
user would move around,
you can slowly build the
experience going forward.
Well, the journey of
understanding the real world
comes with its own
set of challenges.
For instance, as you
see on the screen, when
the environment gets
too dark, ARCore
can detect such situations
and provide feedback.
And today, ARCore can detect
insufficient features, too dark
or low-lit environments
in excessive control.
You can now use
these capabilities
to understand user's
context, and prompt them
with contextual guidance, and
avoid any kind of friction.
Now after you've selected
the type of environment,
your second step would be to
define the experience size.
An experience size
could be a table scale,
as you see on the screen,
room scale, or world scale.
When we design for
table scale, it
allows users to engage in AR
on the smallest of surfaces.
And a tabletop experience
would influence
how you design the scale of your
assets and the potential play
space.
Whereas with room
scale, it basically
expands the potential
for delight and magic.
So you can leverage
multiple surfaces,
create larger-than-life
assets for users to explore
and immerse in the experience.
With world scale, we have
no screen size limits.
You can leverage procedurally
generated content
and build your
experiences with time.
However, public
spaces, you might
encounter some unique challenges
ranging from a difficulty
in tracking an
occlusion depending
on the number of objects in
people present in the scene.
So from the private
space of a room
to the waste openness of
a real-world environment,
consider where users
may be using your app.
And anticipate and
communicate any kind
of potential
challenges that might
hinder their physical
capabilities of movement
in the scene.
And pick spaces that are most
conducive for the task at hand
Users-- what's an experience
without our users, right?
And they are the most excited
and ready-to-be-delighted lot.
Well, with AR, we
have transitioned from
the 3-to-6-inch screen that
used to be in our mobile phones
to a screen size which
has no limits today.
And this creates a completely
new and exciting paradigm
for users to experience.
However, several years of past
smartphone use and the field
of view limited to
that small screen
has led to some
behaviors and habits
that can influence
users' behavior
in an immersive experience.
So I am going to be talking
about these behaviors,
and specifically touch
upon perception, movement,
and comfort as three aspects.
So now let's talk
about perception
and how users' perception
can be defined by a screen.
While using smartphone
applications,
user attention is focused on
the flat screen of the 2D screen
that you see,
whereas in an AR app,
an immersive environment to
the user, the screen size
is limitless.
And that can be defined as seen.
And how could scene influence
user behavior and perception?
Let's figure it out.
When users are experiencing
an AR environment,
their attention is
now being pulled
from what used to be
the screen to the scene
and creating some
sort of immersion.
And immersion is great.
That's what we are
looking for, right?
Users are truly engaged with
your app, and it's good to go.
But there are some kind
of design challenges
that we've come across.
We found that users
can completely forget
about their surroundings.
So they'll be so
immersed in the scene
that, whatever that's around
them, they'll forget about it.
And immersion can limit
users' peripheral vision
and what we call
cognitive tunneling.
The best way to understand would
be that they have blinders on.
And these blinders aren't just
to do with just the surrounding
environment.
Whereas while users are immersed
and engaged in the experience,
don't be surprised if they
completely forget about the UI
that you have on the screen.
And we recommend you to reduce
the number of UI elements
that you have on the screen,
and try and introduce them
in the scene itself.
And wherever we are building any
kind of flows where the user is
allowed to move back and
forth from a screen to scene,
try and make it
either less frequent
or try to avoid that completely.
Now here I have an
interesting concept.
But before I
introduce that to you,
could you tell me what's
happening on screen right now,
anyone?
Anyone?
OK, so yes, a little pet
is being reduced in size.
But what's happening here
is that one on the left
is reducing in the
size, and on the right,
is translating in the scene.
So what we've observed
is that there's
an altered perception in terms
of depth, distance, and scale.
And this is one of
the common behaviors
that our users encounter when
they're experiencing an AR app.
Once they are translating
an object in the scene,
they tend to perceive
it as a change in size.
And one way to solve
this possible challenge
is to encourage user movement
so that users can correctly
interpret the interaction
that you're building in.
Now we talked about perception.
Let's talk about movement.
Mobile AR is inherently
an environmental medium
that invites movement
and motion from the user.
And coming back to
smartphones again,
as I was talking
about it, smartphones
have a strong impact
on user behavior.
And it most evidently
can be seen in movement.
And if you look around,
we feel that we're so
immersed in our smartphones
that we've developed
some sort of an inertia.
So if we are stuck in a place,
we are just stuck in a place.
And we won't move around
until there's a major reason
to change that.
And many of our users
have never experienced
a 360-degree environment.
They're still learning
to comprehend the ability
to use their spaces as
an expansive play space.
Here, from an
engagement standpoint,
they're not only engaging
with your experience,
but now they are actors in
your experience as well.
And you could use movement as
an input for the experience
that you're building.
And I'll be talking
about that going forward.
So now they're stuck at a
situation, or at a pose.
How do you encourage
them to move?
And one approach
that we have here
is to leverage any kind
of off-screen indicators
that encourage users
to flow with them.
And once users
start moving, it'll
be hard for you to figure
out what direction they're
going to move in.
So it'll be good for
you to guide the users
about the kind and
the range of movement
that you intend for your
app, and by creating
a clear directional path
as you see the visual here.
Another approach to
make user movement
as an input to
your gameplay could
be that you could leverage
users' curiosity by placing
objects that are
partially occluded
to encourage them to move.
And it also gives
them more agency
to start exploring the space.
And while we are
talking about movement,
I'm sure you must
be thinking if it
is critical to your
experience or not.
Is it really necessary?
So one thing that
we can keep in mind
is trying to figure out what are
you going to use movement for.
Is it going to be an
input to your experience?
Or is it something that you're
using to explore an object
or play space for the user?
So for instance, as you see
the visual in the screen,
here, there's a bar graph.
So [INAUDIBLE] creating
a utility app experience,
spinning the graph
might just be easier
instead of forcing the
user to move around it.
So be mindful of how you
are using user movement
while creating your app.
And now that we've covered
perception and movement,
I'll be talking about
safety and comfort.
Because that's crucial
for any AR experience.
We've observed,
sometimes, AR experiences
are built for
long-duration game plays.
And holding your phone
still for a really long time
can be very, very tiring.
And you can build
your experience,
which can encourage
either natural movement,
or try and build resting
points in the play cycle.
And when user wants
to pause, or let's
say, walk out of the scene,
help them store the progress,
not lose their data.
And spare them
any kind of effort
that they're going to put
in to reset everything
when they return.
Avoid making the
user do anything
which is physically demanding,
uncomfortable, or abrupt
avoid interactions that require
the user to walk backward
like the way you
see on the visual
here, like pulling a
slingshot sort of a thing.
Remember we talked about
the blinders behavior?
Correctly planning
for this behavior
is even more important
when a user is outdoors.
For example, I'm sharing
AR navigation with you
that we are building right now.
And if a user starts
walking with the phone up,
we try and give a subtle
nudge to pay attention
to their surroundings.
And if they still continue to
walk forward with their phone
up, we insert a bit more
with using a screen overlay.
That effectively prevents the
user from continuing to use AR.
So this is just one
example that we have
where you can optimize
for user safety.
Together, our role
as creators is
to make sure that a product
is not only helpful, but also
responsibly designed.
And now that we have understood
the fundamental concepts
of environment and
user, Germain will
be talking about how to
utilize some of these concepts
and build AR content
in your experience.
GERMAIN RUFFLE:
Thank you, Khushboo.
Yeah, hi, everyone.
My name is Germain.
I'm a UX designer
on the ARCore team.
And I'm going to walk you
through the next big step
in your journey of
developing an AR
app, which is the AR content.
So basically, for
the next 10 minutes,
I'm going to talk about
how to display AR content
and how to interact with it.
So the first question
you should ask yourself
before thinking about adding
content to the user environment
is, how would this content
fit in their surroundings--
basically, how to make
this object look real.
And when I'm talking
about real or realism,
it's not much about having
realistic object in the scene,
but more about entering the
presence of any kind of object
in the environment.
The goal here is basically to
maintain the user's suspension
of disbelief by making sure
that your augmented content
feels present and credible.
This is really
important so the user
can be immersed
in your experience
and believe in the story
you're trying to tell them.
In order to achieve
this presence,
there are multiple
levers you can play with.
And I'm going to walk you
through three major ones.
The first one is actually
happening during the creation
of the asset itself.
Because today, AR mostly
means smartphone AR.
It comes inherently with
certain constraints,
specifically when
it comes to graphic.
So you need to find
creative solution
to achieve the aesthetics
you're targeting.
A very cost-efficient way of
improving definition and level
of detail of a model is to
use a multi-layer texture
model such as PBR, Physically
Based Rendering model.
Supported by most
AR development tool,
this is the cheapest solution
to achieve an advanced degree
of detail for your objects.
And it works
perfectly fine in AR.
For example, you can
see on the screen,
by adding normal
maps to the object,
I'm adding a lot of detail, a
lot of wrinkles to the asset
without any additional geometry.
The second element you
want to pay attention
while designing your
experience is the lighting.
As Alex mentioned
previously, ARCore
is now coming with
a new set of APIs
that will help you to create
dynamic lighting and shadowing.
AR contents would
then react accurately
to the real-world changing
of lighting-- changement
of lighting.
This is a very crucial
factor to ensure realism,
as a wrong lighting would
instantly break the immersion.
And if you want to go beyond
with dynamic lighting,
you can also imagine using
lighting as a trigger--
as a trigger behavior or
condition for your gameplay.
As you can see here,
not only the asset
is reacting to the
changement of lighting,
but it's also
adding a new content
based on the fact that
the lighting is changing.
And finally, another element
that you can play with
to increase the credibility
of your experience
is to emulate real-life
physics and apply this
to your virtual object.
This will not only
bring a lot of realism,
but can also create some fun
scene and delightful situations
such as the one here,
where, basically, an object
is moving from one object to
another without any user input.
So now that we have defined
how your object will
look like in AR, it is important
to think about how they would
behave, and more
specifically, how would a user
interact with the assets?
For the past couple
of months, we've
been conducting
a lot of research
to define our object
manipulation model.
And we are really happy to
share it with you today.
We basically found
10 attributes that we
feel can contribute to create
a good object manipulation
model for AR.
The first attribute is to
always have a selection state.
Regardless of the number of
elements you have in the scene,
it is important that
the other can precisely
select one of them
before applying
any transformation to it.
Although it is important
to visually communicate
that the object is selected,
we call that selected state.
So as you can see
here, we are using
a ring that not only show
that the object is selected,
but also show the surface
it is currently placed on.
There is many different
way of showing
that an object's selected.
Feel free to create
your own that would
fit best with your aesthetic.
The second attribute
is for user movement.
So one of the first
things ever user
would do when trying
an AR experience
is to move the object around.
That's why we
decided on creating
very simple interaction, a
one-finger touch and drag.
It is a very common gesture,
and people are really
used to it from 2D apps.
If the user is trying to
move an object further away,
they can also maintain the
touch on the object and move
physically with their
phone in the space.
It is also crucial to make
sure that the user can
select the object and move
it in one single touch.
This would avoid
a lot of friction.
While moving an object from
one surface to another,
be sure to maintain
height of the objects.
So it always stays under
the finger of the user.
Also, it can be a good idea
to highlight the destination
point of the object
on the next surface
to help the user
precisely place it.
When a user is moving
an object in distance,
it is important to increase
the size of the invisible touch
area, or hit box, in regards to
its distance from the screen.
Otherwise, the user won't be
able to bring back an asset
that they've pushed
away without having
to physically move towards it.
And for the exact
same reason, you
want to make sure that you have
a minimum and maximum placement
distance, ensuring that
the user can always
interact with the assets
without having to walk and look
for them.
When it comes to
rotating an object,
there are basically two
methods that we recommend.
We found that most
users would first
try a two-finger twist on the
screen to rotate the object.
This is like the most commonly
used interaction in 2D apps.
However, one-finger rotation
feels more natural in AR
since the swipe gesture
maps to the axis
of rotation of the object.
So we basically
recommend to implement
both methods to support both
discoverability and also more
natural interaction.
The next attribute
is about scaling.
So this would work
exactly like what
you would expect in
any other 2D app,
performing a pinch or to
change the size of the object.
Since two fingers are
also used for rotation,
adding a slight threshold can
be helpful to disambiguate
between the two interactions.
And because we are in AR, it
is crucial for your object
to have a minimum
and maximum size.
So this will ensure that
the users don't make objects
so small or so large that
they can no longer interact
with them.
You can communicate that the
user reach the boundaries
by adding a small bounce effect,
as you can see on the screen.
The next attribute is
about elevating an object.
After a lot of
research, we discovered
that the most affordant
way of elevating an object
is to perform a two-finger
vertical swipe on the screen,
up and down.
Also, I want to bring
your attention to the fact
that it is important
to visually connect
the assets to the surface
that it's placed on.
This will help the
user understand
both which object is
selected and what effect they
are having on this object.
And the final attribute that
I'm going to talk about today
is about negative elevation.
In a few words, do not let
objects sink into the surface
they are placed on.
Not only would it break the
rule of physics and instantly
breaking the
immersion, but also, it
can, on a more practical
level, lead to a situation
where the user may lose
assets by bringing them
below the ground level.
So basically, to
sum up, we've put
a lot of research and refinement
in creating our AR object
manipulation model.
And we hope that our
findings can really
benefit to all of you.
And because we know that
a good demo is always
better than words, we've
created an open source demo
as part of the ARCore SDK
that you can download today.
And that implements all
these attributes for you.
You can download the
SDK today and quickly
add object manipulation
into your project.
So now I'm going to give
the stage to Eugene, who's
going to continue walking
us through the journey
of developing an AR app and
talking about UI components.
EUGENE MENG: Perfect.
Thanks, Germain.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Eugene.
I'm also an interaction
designer on the ARCore UX team.
Today I will be introducing
you to the last building
block of designing for
AR, being interface.
Historically, every
successful platform
has introduced a
set of UI widgets
for developers to
craft applications.
And this AR is a
nascent field itself.
We are also exploring
which set of UI components
makes the most sense for
volumetric applications.
If you think about
it, the interface
is the viewport for AR
that helps magically bridge
the gap between users
and the environment.
The size of a phone screen
is literally the size
of a user's field of view.
It also serves as a control
panel for your users
to magically manipulate AR
content through gestures
or UI widgets.
And knowing that the interface
accounts for both view
and input, as creators, we want
to create an interface that's
engaging, intuitive, yet clean
to not block users' view.
And to start with, some familiar
2D screen UI patterns do
carry over to AR, especially
in initialization and settings
controls.
A lot of applications feature a
combination of 2D and AR modes.
And in those apps,
the journey of AR
starts from the moment when
a user tap on the Launch
into AR Mode button.
Google has now created a
set of call to action icons
for accessing AR with
different intentions.
The icon set features a
consistent bracket frame
metaphor, symbolizing
launching into AR experiences
in the camera--
in the camera viewfinder.
And we believe that
using consistent UI icons
across applications will greatly
help acknowledge user entrance
into AR.
And as indicated
in the iconography,
AR experiences are heavily
dependent on camera
see-throughs.
However, through
research, we have
found that majority
of users, especially
those who are not
familiar with AR,
will drop off during a
denaturalization stage
when they're asked to give
permission to their camera
usage, which is simply not
something that is required
for most 2D applications.
This means that
most of the users
don't even get to experience
AR and have already
left the experience
without realizing it.
Acknowledging that, we
recommend you, as creators,
to communicate the
intent of camera usage
explicitly before
permission prompts
to help give your users more
context on why camera usage is
necessitated for the
experience you have built.
And in cases where
2D screen UIs are
present during runtime,
like settings controls or 2D
galleries, it is important
for these UI components
to feature responsiveness.
The UI components should
remain at the same location,
but rotate in reaction
to the device orientation
to enhance for user comfort.
And meanwhile, you don't
want to interrupt the camera
feed with a rotation animation.
The feed itself will give
you the visual feedback.
Knowing that the real
estate of your phone screen
is really limited and
precious, a great way
to help make more room on
your screen with realism
into the AR fabric is through
leveraging more volumetric UI.
UI components like
icons, chips, and cards
translate well to
annotate AR objects
with different
volume of information
with nuanced and
spatial behaviors.
We would love to think
of these behaviors
as volumetric responsive design.
Uniquely, AR annotations can
vary their physical forms
in reaction to user movement
and interactions, such as focus
and select.
To maintain legibility of
information and add delight,
we suggest you to
define a minimum default
and maximum target
size for annotations
to be displayed at
different movement range
with varied amount of info.
This rule also applies to
different selection states
to help inform context.
Where users are
moving their devices
between different
annotations, you
will want the one that's
currently being on focus
or that's currently
being selected
to be shown in its
full size or form,
whereas the other
ones can optionally
stay at a reduced form.
On top of that, AR
annotations can also
rotate to preserve readability
and deliver a context.
Like what you can
see here on the left,
having an annotation to
always rotate to face a user
can be overwhelming at times,
especially when your user is
constantly moving in
their space or when
there are multiple annotations
in the scene at the same time.
Knowing that, we suggest
you have annotations
remain static and only rotate
when it is on focus so that we
can maintain readability
of these annotations
and inform context
when necessary.
Another thing to
note is that when
you're designing for
these rotation behaviors,
we suggest you to be mindful
of the spatial relationship
between the annotations
and other virtual objects
to avoid collision.
Similar to the
responsiveness of texts,
objects can also adapt
the size to environment.
You can use a hologram to
offer a preview for users
to understand the volume
and scale of the object.
This greatly helps
set their expectation
before placing or anchoring an
object firmly at a location.
And this will help
to set up your scenes
with a lot more success.
And in cases where a
virtual object does appear
to intersect with a real-world
entity like a wall in a room,
you also want to
communicate visually
how much space is needed
for a proper placement
so that you can prompt your
user to move and reanchor
the object.
Another way to look at the
responsiveness of object
is the adjustment of elevation.
Physical environments are
not always perfectly designed
for AR experiences.
For instance, let's say you're
designing for a tabletop
experience like a chess
game where your users simply
don't have a table
in their environment.
What should we do?
We suggest to just go ahead and
create a virtual table that's
generated based on
your device orientation
and the distance
between the device
and the detected surface.
This gives your user flexibility
to align the experience based
on their eye level and optimize
for ease of access and user
comfort.
And like Khushboo has
mentioned earlier,
when users are fully
immersed in the AR
story, most of the times, we
don't want to interrupt that.
We have observed situations
when users are freely
exploring around in
the AR experience
and would occasionally
approach their device closer
to an object to
simply test and see
if it's a point of interest,
which sometimes ends up
in surface collision
between the device screen
and the surface of
the virtual object,
causing the virtual object to
suddenly disappear from your AR
experience.
In order to inform
your users that this
is an unintended behavior,
instead of triggering
an interruptive
warning notification,
we suggest to handle
it more elegantly.
One way you can do it is to
have and use camera effect
to subtly convey the idea
that users are entering
an unexpected territory
while still keep
their attention in the scene.
In 2D interface design,
notifications sometimes
show up in forms of pop-ups.
In AR, we want to
avoid this usage
unless users intentionally
choose to launch them.
The ones that are
showing up out of blue
can easily take
over the viewport
and instantly breaks
realism by shifting
your user's mental
model from the scene
back to a screen-based
browsing experience.
Now that we have talked a lot
about design basics [INAUDIBLE]
quality AR, we're also super,
super excited to introduce you
to a set of tools that are
available over ARCore platform
to help you, as
creators, to embark
on a journey of AR production.
We're constantly launching
updates for ARCore
with a set of SDKs that you
can simply grab off the rack
and hopefully expedite
your project development.
In a recent release, we have
shared a couple of demo scenes
with image tracking
and all above
mentioned behaviors
of object manipulation
that you can use and customize.
You can also download
the ARCore Elements app
from Play Store, where
you can find and play
with all the UI components
that we have shared today.
And if you're into
reading, we also
have a textual documentation
of all of our learnings packed
into an augmented reality design
guidelines that's available
online.
Feel free to check
out these resources
and keep them by
your side when you're
working on your AR projects.
And since AR is peaking
over its horizon,
we'd love to see more
inspiration spawned
from your project.
And hopefully we'll be able
to see more lessons learned
and questions raised about AR.
Thank you for joining us today
in person or on live stream.
Hope you enjoy your time at I/O.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]